my dad's old volvo 240 had a hand crank
uh in the ceiling ceiling uh roof
[ __ ] sunroof
okay yeah i just couldn't remember what
the roof of the car was called i wanted
to call it the ceiling which it
technically kind of still is it's the
ceiling yeah a ceiling is just whatever
you put above your head my man that's
true come on dude
a ceiling is where you make it you get
under that couch baby that's a ceiling
that's true in and of itself
i almost took an edible before this and
i'm so glad that i didn't we should have
gotten high
i'd be down to do that one time yeah you
should be on acid again i'm down to do
that
i have no issue with that so when i was
leaving boston my flight got canceled
and it's something i just did it say
something on twitter or something what
your flight
did you like
on twitter
sorry
that was good i'm sorry dude yeah go on
it got canceled yeah my my flight said
the eff slur on twitter oh during pride
month double oh
god that's a no-no there was a whole
segment on it on tv yeah this
747 cancelled
after its ai went rogue and tweeted the
epsler
i would love to see what an airplane ai
would tweet they're just interviewing
the dials it's just going crazy it's
just super homophobic
well no go on no no no you can imagine
no imagine yeah yeah sure
so so your flight got canceled yeah got
cancelled
yeah
so um
well hopefully you know
a little an apology with tears video and
it'll be back on tour yeah no it got
cancelled and i haven't seen that happen
a lot did you you saw the video of the
dude getting the that united employee
getting his [ __ ] rocked i think you must
have it was like a few weeks ago on the
plane where your backdrop is yeah he
pushed the guy first yeah and then the
guy fought back yeah good for the guy
you should do that i'm bringing this up
because boston pushed me to like two
moments where i kind of understood why
people become karen's like i almost had
you ever had a karen moment i've never
had i've never had that i have but i
contain it yeah i almost like i had one
where i almost didn't on this trip yeah
i was eating some restaurant and we
brought ollie and they're kind of being
shitty about
us just having them we're like sitting
outside like on a sidewalk and they're
like
yeah well technically he can't be in the
restaurant i'm like he's not in the
restroom we are outside
and they were just being dicks about it
and uh
i
i almost like wanted to snap and be like
what if i told you
legally you can't ask me if he is so
then what i've never felt that like the
want to like get in a [ __ ] regular
person's face yeah you know regular
person what a shitty thing to say it's a
it's just a an innocent person's face
yeah but in this case they weren't
really innocent
yeah or like like i've never want to
yell at an employee like that sure it
was crazy and i had to like it took
everything in my body to just like not
do it and again in the airport
but i didn't he's like you can tie him
up over there like three feet away he's
like but he can't be in the restaurant
and i looked at the pole and i looked at
him and i went
and that's it and then we just like kind
of he was like okay
and i just shook my head and i just kept
eating it
for you it just held ollie there and
then i was waiting for it i was waiting
for him to come back out and he kept
making eye contact with me because he's
delivering more food yeah and i had it
cocked and ready if he came back and was
like i really need you i was gonna just
be like you mind grabbing me a bunch of
to-go boxes then so i can get all this
to leave yeah and then just eat it
slowly and just [ __ ] just be as petty
as possible i never felt that i never
felt a cairnism
like have you ever acted on one five six
years ago i mean you shot a restaurant
worker
no no
no
i was uh i was in new york
dead of summer super hot i'm on uh
i can't remember the jay-z
uh train which is outside it's jay-z
training yeah the jmz
no no
oh my god i thought he was referring to
a train that jay-z like mentioned in a
song
that'd be cool and i i actually have
wondered aloud like hey did he name
himself after the train because it says
jay-z and he's from brooklyn and it goes
through brooklyn it's a sensible
question okay sure so
uh i'm standing out there waiting with
my girlfriend at the time
and i look over and i see this guy
kind of cracked out tweaked out looking
yeah and he's
scoping out these two women like in a
really gross way who are right next to
him and then he kind of digs through the
trash and i just was like keeping my eye
on him because i'm like this guy looks
like he's a tweaker yeah and then he
looked up from the trash and saw me
looking at him and he comes over and he
just goes hey
do i know you
and i just thought you know my
adrenaline immediately is like
yeah and i'm like
i'm just being friendly i'm like nah i
don't think so when he goes because
you're looking at me like you know me oh
and then my girlfriend
is a native new yorker she immediately
is like okay no we're not doing this so
she comes over and goes no we're not and
then he interrupts her and goes shut the
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
and i just i just thought oh no
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
damn it and i just kind of like
said
you can't talk to her like that
something like that all right and i just
i just thought okay i've gotta okay i
guess i have to like put my body between
them and as i said that and then he like
he
grabbed me by the collar of my shirt
like this and he said like what are you
gonna do about it or something like that
i just kind of
i just said like
you know get your hands on me
i don't remember
but my girlfriend thank god just said
like we're leaving walk away and i
didn't think that that was possible my
flight my fight flight or sh you know
[ __ ] yourself was getting the poop ready
yeah and
she just pulls me away
and we walked away and
for the rest of the day yeah whenever i
had a spare minute whenever i went to
the bathroom i was googling
like
it the autocomplete basically already
answers what to do when someone grabs
your shirt
and all the like self-def defense videos
the first thing that they walk you
through is
let's say someone grabs you by the shirt
i'm just like [ __ ] why couldn't i have
seen any of these videos beforehand what
do they say to do they say all sorts of
things there are literally like two
dozen things you can do you can like
grab their hand and just choke them yeah
like take their arm down and for the
rest of the day i'm just fantasizing
about it yeah i'm fantasizing about what
i could have done that would have made
me the hero of the subway platform what
i would do if i saw the guy again i'm
thinking like oh
if if i see this gentleman again it is
game over it is game over because
i would see him and be like hey grab my
shirt
come here grab my shirt
no you with your left hand grab it and
i'd i'd be ready to take him down of
course and i you know he's probably dead
or in prison but you know
if he's not i i ha buddy i hope you're
doing well out there
[ __ ] face
um
nice yeah look at me now
go i dare you to come grab my shirt
again
but yeah so that was my one
moment where
i i now have something prepared
so what have we got man
no no this is way better this is way
better you getting grabbed by a homeless
drug addict
going
let me go it's like as i started to say
it i could feel like my voice cracking
as if i were about to cry but i'm like
but i'm not about to cry stop sounding
like you're gonna cry
you